welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss it's the end of the year of 2023
and Marvel Studios is scaling back in
full effect in 2024 but you know what
there are lots of other movies that we
at new rockstars are looking ahead at
and other TV shows where that we just
excited about in the new year we've
we've seen new trailers for The Boys
House of the Dragon Dune part two
furiosa Godzilla xcong they've all
dropped in the past few weeks we are
counting down our top five most
anticipated movies and TV shows of 2024
and of course I say we because this is a
sneak peek where we're taking the
temperature of the future of nerd D and
joining me to look ahead into 2024 my
number one Jessica Clemens hi oh number
one but I just did a number
two thank you for sharing for starting
up New Year bit of honesty I'm going to
rep I'm going to call back to it so many
times
throughout this and we're never that no
I'm joking you keep it you keep it it's
funny it's the New Year I'm trying to be
a comedian okay well let's do we're
going to alternate we're going to start
with uh Jess number five then my number
five and we'll go down and if there's
any overlap we'll just talk about it uh
when we get to the higher ranking
because the person who ranked it higher
clearly cares about it more that is true
all right Jess we'll start what is your
number five most anticipated film of
2024 my number five so lowest on the
list but also still very high it didn't
it's it's perfect where it is I'm doing
Wicked and you know damn well you know
damn well is because I'm a musical
theater lover and I'm very excited to
see what it's gonna do and you got two
of the like what greatest TV Ser I say
TV singers because I only know Ariana
Grande for that one Nickelodeon show but
I'm like she's has a great voice Cynthia
is amazing I'm so excited to see what
it's going to do one of my favorite
musical of all time oh my God this is
going to be incredible Chu of crazy Rich
Asians is directing it uh Wicked I went
through a wicked phase in high school
where I was obsessed with it I worked at
a Boy Scout summer camp and I didn't
tell the other guys I worked with but
literally every day on my break I would
go back and nap and I would Listen to
Wicked and just chill out just like good
news and at some point someone grabbed
the headphones off my head and they're
like what are you listening to and it
was like something bad is happening in
Oz and I was like give me those no no no
uh like something bad is like the worst
song the others are good that's okay
that's me with and I'm I only say it's
the worst song because I'm just
embarrassed because it is the song But
like I auditioned so so many musicals
with popular that it's insane it's one
of the best shows I was like I was like
this is me let's do it I love this
number five though number five on my
list and isn't it like Wicked part one
aren't they doing like two wickeds there
going to be two that's what I'm scared
about that's the part that I'm scared
about but I love crazy Rich Asians he
will never come back with a second one
I'm looking Direct in the camera for
this because I need you to come up with
a second I don't know I I don't know if
they will I don't know they're never
going to yeah I don't know jechan is
never gonna get her story and I'm very
upset about
it but regardless I'm very excited for
Wicked I'm only nervous about it being
two parts but I'm gonna go see it um I
mean that finale just doing Defying
Gravity to end a film like that will be
an insane that's going to blow people's
minds although will it have the same
effect on screen that it will on stage
you have to like she's going to have to
Belt it and I'm going to have to feel it
in the chair like I'm seeing in IMAX but
like she's going to have to do a lot for
that to like transfer from stage to film
uh on film I'll just be like oh yeah of
course uh on stage I was like this woman
is defying grabbit she's flying she
she's literally flying and then they do
intermission right then it was go
intermission okay my number five is
Pixar's Inside Out too uh obviously I'm
a little biased um my wife wife works on
this movie at Pixar but I'm so excited
for this movie it's it looks so good we
had it we saw a teaser for it uh uh the
first Inside Out was such an important
movie for me I literally watched it the
week in my apartment burn down and I I
just needed some like healing and I went
to go see that movie and it was like I
was sobbing the whole time and I was
like yes our feelings can change over
time and like we need sadness we need
grief that helps us heal
so just I mean I just know the people
working on this movie are some of the
like brightest and um most like
thoughtful most empathetic storytellers
so I'm just really excited to see what
they do with it I will never not cry it
inside out and I didn't put it on this
list because I'm not ready to cry in
2024 my New Year's resolution not crying
I'm not crying once all of 2024 bet
believe it um and that will make me cry
look nothing here I'm so excited for
inside out too it's going to be so
freaking good it's going to be so good
I'm so excited um oh my god do you want
to know my four yeah what's your number
four my number four is Beetle Juice to
and before anyone says anything
Wednesday turned out to be a pretty good
show and so that's where I'm like I am
excited to see what they're going to do
with Beetlejuice 2 and also bringing
back Michael Keon is the most insane
unhinged idea and they're doing it
they're doing it you know that could it
could work it could work there's the
first Beetle Juice is a very weird movie
he's an everything too who tries to
marry a
teenager it works
so we all were like damn that's crazy
not none of us were like this is a
problem this is weird it's funny too
because in the Beetle Juice musical they
address it they're always like this is
uh this is kind of like they keep saying
it they say it not me they're like this
is kind of like a green card thing uh
and I'm always like this is crazy that
this is how they address it in the
musical uh but no I'm excited I Jen
Ortega changed my life uh so I'm very
excited all right my number four is
furiosa a Mad Max Saga okay um I'm
surprised had four it's at four there's
three other movies I'm just a bit more
excited and here's I was expecting to
put this at number one because Mad Max
uh Fury Road is my favorite movie of
2015 this movie I think looks really
good that trailer got me going I didn't
really see the CGI issues that people
had but I think that there are like
other places that I think fans of the
Fury Road could have taken it with like
furiosa after the Citadel but I do like
that this preserves her ending as
reclaiming The Citadel and we get to see
another chapter of her life uh like
because I don't know how else you build
out I mean to have to maybe have Max be
kind of like another helper to some
other group of people in this Wasteland
would be a way to go but um I'm still
really excited for it just because I
think think George Miller with this
franchise can do no wrong he's got the
amazing that's such an amazing crew
working with him in Australia like it's
going to be great I'm very excited for
that one funny enough didn't make it on
my list okay very very weirdly did not
make it on my list and I probably should
now that I think about it but these
three spots are very important uh these
next three spots my number three is
Deadpool three is that weird for a
middle is that weird for a middle no I
think that's a good spot to put it I
have higher on my list so let's uh let's
save let's save it for now yeah let's
save it for now U my number three is we
don't know anything about this movie but
we know it's coming we know the director
it is Jordan peele's fourth film you
can't say that yes I can you can't
choose something that doesn't even exist
yet yes I can I mean I mean I know he's
gonna come out with a movie it's coming
he's shooting it we don't know anything
about it we'll probably hear soon maybe
around the Super Bowl we'll hear what it
is it's set for Christmas 2024 or like
Thanksgiving 2024 but it's coming in the
calendar year 2024 and the man has made
three films and I have loved each of
them so I think I'm just gonna love the
third one so I'm sorry tell all you
Pixar and furiosa heads Jordan peele's
movie it's just it's right my top three
if I knew I could have put a movie that
didn't exist yet uh on the list I
probably would have put it as my number
one uh because
I no because my number one makes sense
my number one I like I'm rooted in the
ground for and I have been for a very
long time but my number two which is
kind of weird my number two could slly
interchange with number three but number
two is a little bit higher than number
three and it's Dune two okay so I'm
gonna do this dud again Dune two is
higher for me so let's talk about
Deadpool 3 and then Dune and then we'll
hear what your mystery number one is so
just to quickly spoil it my number two
was Deadpool 3 my number one is Dune
part two let's about what what are you
excited about with Deadpool 3 I'm
excited for everything I think the
reason why I'm excited for everything
I'm so confused but also very excited
for everything that we've heard about it
but because of everything that has been
released all those set photos everything
that we seeing I'm seeing enough that
I'm like oh I'm still anticipating it
I'm so excited for it but the other two
I don't know enough about I have not
seen a lot of the behind the-scenes
photos I haven't seen any no one has
talked about anything else so I'm like
oh I'm just I I'm like excited for Dune
2 a little bit more just because I
haven't seen a lot of the information
that uh is being released online for
Deadpool 3 I feel exactly the same way
Deadpool 3 I think there's a reason why
Marvel is okay making that it's one
theatrical release of 2024 I you know
you have an amazing team here of you
know Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman and
Shan Levy and like everyone else that
they convinced to come back for it I
think it's gonna be a real celebration
of Marvel's history I think it's gonna
be a lot of fun in exactly what Marvel
needs right now um I think you just have
a star studded cast just with the two of
them uh and the only reason why it's not
my number one is just like is the Sha
Levy of it all sha Ley I think is great
he seems like a really nice guy he's got
this Gavin Newsome thing going on wa to
make it too political just the way he
talks he's got this grin on his face
it's this California smile you know like
whatever you want to call that but
anyway he's just he hasn't made only
perfect films and two of the directors
that I have on my list or no three of
the directors I've had on my list have
only really made great movies so um I
just think sha Levy like some of the
choices he's made with stranger things
just get a little indulgent um a free
guy I think was just an okay movie so
there's a chance I think it'll still be
really really good it's my number two I
think Sean Levy is very good for
Deadpool 3 and that's what choices for
stranger things valid understandable
free guy or yeah free Guy Crazy uh chaos
n of the museum also chaos but I think
those can apply very well to Deadpool
three well and the reason I mean Dune
part two I just think the first dune was
such an incredible film I think Dune
part two is going to be even better
Denny Ville new understands this Source
material so well uh and dune part two
goes to even like the second half of
Frank Herbert's novel just goes to if
anything reading the book feels a little
like H like it's like a Sci-Fi slog
because uh so many other things whether
it's Star Wars or Blade Runner or a lot
of other properties have kind of like
made poppy versions of it so it feels a
little like dated but they've lost what
was so good about Frank Herbert's novel
which is like exposing the hypocrisy and
[__] of a Chosen One mythology um
and how it's all just corrupted by
political influence and uh
anti-religious bias and pro-religious
bias and all this stuff so I think Dune
part 2 is gonna go to these really dark
places I think Disney Ville new is gonna
shoot it to look already has shot it to
look amazing it's my most anticipated
movie of 2024 by sh after hearing this
I'm like yeah Dune should have been my
number one but no wait did you see your
third was what was your third yeah yeah
so my top five were uh Inside Out 2 the
number four was furiosa number three was
Jordan peele's fourth movie ha you
that's why I forgot it that's why I
forgot it three was dead number one was
Dune okay perfect my number
one and this is this is Jessica Clemens
this is Jessica Clemens choosing number
one not like Jessica the film scholar
choosing number one um because I would
have probably chose Dune is incredible I
am obsessed with Dune it is I'm I'm so
excited for it but I'm slightly more
excited for Joker
too I almost put it on my list
Jo a good pick good pick I'm
waiting I am seated waiting for that
goddamn movie to drop I have so the what
we have seen from like just people
taking photos of them shooting in La uh
to what it's supposed to be to
Lady Gaga I'm just like I had to say it
that way I genuinely am so enamored with
what it could be and what it should be
and what it's probably going to be and I
need to know and I'm feasting waiting
upon it Dune I'm like yeah I'm gonna go
see this I'm so excited but this I'm
like I better be there before anyone can
spoil it for me and I better be the
first row like watching it looking up
cranking my neck dying so that's my
number one movie that I've been waiting
for is jok I think it's a valid Choice
it n narrowly missed out in my top five
slot I'm super pumped for that I'm
surprised it it's funny because it
shouldn't be like a it's not a it's not
a five it's not a on the like the list
it's not at the bottom of the list it's
not a five it's definitely not a four
but it should be in the top three of
people's most anticipated I think it
could be the Barbie of 2024 a movie that
people are like have hesitation for but
it just has some magic to it that people
lose their minds it feels like it is
going to be Barbie and Oppenheimer put
together uh spliced together is going to
be the Joker part two or the Joker 2 I'm
just I eat that movie up and I'm sorry I
eat it up left off of our mentions
completely have been Godzilla X Kong
have been the new plan of the Apes movie
Craven Madam
web uh beyond the spiderverse might come
out 20124 but I believe it's been pushed
to
2025 uh yeah do we feel any regrets that
we left out some uh some huge pick no
I'm good I I think yeah I was like I
think I'm solid uh curious about the
other ones that we list off but I'm not
as anticipated as like the top five that
we've given um yeah and also our top
five is definitely speak to ourselves
and it's like yeah these are exactly
what Jessica and Eric would be
anticipating uh I'm excit I'm gonna go
see the other movies of course I will
yes you think I'm not going to see uh a
King Kong movie that's crazy yeah for
sure I'm going to be lining up for that
one um all right we're going to do the
same thing for our TV shows uh but first
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video you can love holiday season
and also admit that it's stressful
travel time with family marking time
with new years's it can be a lot and if
you feel like you could use a little
help with it all try connecting with a
licensed therapist by using better help
starting therapy can be hard the right
therapist for you may not be in your
area and some people struggle with the
face-to-face interaction of therapy with
better help you can have your therapy
sessions as a phone call a video chat
even via messaging if you prefer that
whatever is the most comfortable version
of therapy for you just click the link
in the description and answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
a therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who's
in your network or anything like that if
you think that you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars clicking
that link helps support support this
Channel and also gets you 10% off your
first month of better help so that you
can connect with a therapist and see if
it helps you be sure to check out nerd
ride. shop where you can always grab the
latest and greatest new rockstars gear
we just put up some new designs inspired
by what if season 2 hey what a great
show that was guys that finale
incredible
right oh my God so support the channel
and check out our great birch options of
nerd rot. shop and don't forget to
subscribe to all three channels of new
rockstars Network the breaker and new
rockstars and the Deep dive all right
let's jump into television SL
streaming uh and we'll do the same thing
so my number five this is hard I I it's
crazy because a lot of TV shows have
been like bumped but or a lot of movies
been bumped but the TV shows are still
there and I'm like or yeah we don't know
yet yeah or we don't know yeah that's
true but I'm like I know these five and
I think there's more on the list for
sure than there were for movies that I'm
missing and I'm actually disappointed
that I couldn't put on the list my
number five is starting with stranger
things and it's very low on the list I
understand but I think it's because
compared to the other series that I put
on my list we spent the most time with
stranger things um it's the closing of
stranger things and unless they kill a
child I'm not gonna be happy what we all
are saying the same we're all saying the
same thing we're all saying the same
thing kill a child I yeah I completely
agree um stranger thingss did not make
my list but narrowly did it's just as
the seasons of stranger things have gone
on I've just missed the glory of that
first season it's just lost a bit more
of its luster I think season 4 was
really good it's just it was indulgently
long for some of those episodes and they
dropped it all well they didn't no they
did in two chunks so never mind but it
felt like I think it was one of the
episodes where I was like this does not
need to be that long I was like I don't
need every point of view of every single
child in this especially this one that's
gonna die in The Next Episode uh but
anyways I think I pump for it though I
think it'll be fun I think I'm also I
put it as my number five because we're
we've been all watching the show for so
long it's one of those shows where it's
like yeah I'm not not going to watch
this and as soon as it drops I'm going
to watch it um we are keeping up with it
we are obsessed with the lore so I put
it that's why it's my number five it's
my number five my number five is X-Men
97 that's interesting we don't know for
sure as of this taping when it's going
to drop and we think it's going to be
2024 Kevin feige keeps bringing it up in
interviews so I think he's like ready to
drop it I love the the '90s Animated
Series I don't think they would have
brought this back if they're going to do
something that just feels completely
like too much just for kids I think
they're going to be doing a lot of
interesting stuff in X-Men 97 I think
we're gonna be shocked like it's GNA be
like what what if was you know how what
is season one and season two just like
we felt that like what what even is this
show is it for kids and then
surprisingly it's like emotionally
moving and has some great animation some
great action yeah this Show's going to
rock I think it's going to be amazing
I'm GNA love it but I do think it's
going to have the same feel that X-Men
97 did have before where I'm or the
original yeah I think it's gonna feel
like that and that would by proxy still
make it kind of a kid show I don't think
it's gonna be as crazy as what if
because what if can came out now uh and
I think it's the Nostalgia for X-Men 97
that people are excited to go see it and
I just don't think that they're gonna
make it that crazy I think it's gonna be
like
but maybe I'm wrong Maybe I'm Wrong I've
been wrong A lot of times in my
life I've been wrong A lot of times in
my life okay my number four is Arcane
and it always will be Arcane because
Arcane is a great yeah it always be
number four I don't care how good that
show is a staying in number
four and Arcane is supposed to come out
in around Christmas or is I think it's
like November or winter of 2024 we're
all hoping it should I think it's a
great show I'm very excited for where
it's going to go I love the first season
it's beautiful it's impeccable it's
great and the fourth season or the
second season better be just as good so
I'm watching it that's my number four I
need to get caught up on Arcane I gotta
watch it so good I watched it in one
night because I got so obsessed with it
it was addictive uh it was insane how
alluring it was and the second season
will just be just be just as good I've
been waiting forever we're all waiting
my number four is as of the St we don't
have a release date but I think it's
going to be 2024 the acolyte the Star
Wars series oh the acolyte you're you're
excited for the acolyte I not me not in
a mean way so excited for the acolyte
Leslie Hedland uh and Ken Moss is going
to be in the acolyte I don't think K and
Moss I mean k and Moss also did Matrix
uh resurrections and that movie was poo
H sck but the acolyte looks from just
like the you know the footage that's you
know I I was able to see leak from
whatever celebration was I think that
show is gonna be so cool I think it's
gonna be really good I'm so iar I just
don't hear a lot of people talking about
it and and maybe it's because there's
like a lot of stuff going on right now
that they're like there's a lot of
things but I'm like oh yeah the acolyte
everybody please go watch it there is a
lot of people in the acolyte that I love
more than anything F I'm very excited
for it I hope everybody watches it and
everybody loves it just like they loved
Andor okay this is is annoying this is
frustrating but my number three is House
of the Dragon is Hot D is the hot okay
that's my number three as well yay we
did it well I'm nervous what your your
two are because you put X-Men as you put
weird you put weird ones as your five I
have some weird picks there's probably
going to be other shows that come out um
House of the Dragon would be higher but
there's just like it's not like season
three Game of Thrones but it's still
really good TV uh and I'm I'm super
because now like the weird stuff of
season one of House of the Dragon is
behind us of the weird time jumps and uh
us just getting to know an actor and
then they get recast in episode six or
whatever no we got our cast locked in
it's a great cast these are some really
good actors and we have some really
really insane drama that's ahead of us
from Fire and Blood and I'm pumped I'm
scared I'm scared having like read the
book being like Oh how much of this part
are they going to
take I yeah I think it's number three
only because I'm excited for the other
two a little bit more but I am dude
house when House of the Dragon was on
those nights of watching it it it did it
felt like Game of Thrones again of like
everybody get down we're watching
Everybody Get On We're watching get off
Twitter do everything you can like we
were it was like lock down you had to
watch it it was so nice and I want that
Vibe back so bad so that's why it's at
my three oh my number two my number two
I don't even know if I don't know I
don't know about you my number two is
echo my number two is Echo I need to see
it I need to see it I just need to see
it and I that trailer is insane no one
thought we were gonna get a freaking
like with the most respect the most
respect Echo none of us were thinking we
were G get like a a guy Richie style
British like gangster gangster trailer I
was like this is crazy there's a lot of
blood this is insane I was not expecting
some literal like thug ass trailer and
it was it feels like what GTA trailers
are it was so dark and gritty it felt
like something that would be on FX I I
need to see it I need to see it um and
greatest birthday gift they could ever
give me Ekko did not make my top five it
would have made my top 10 uh would have
made what do you mean understandable
wait no I'm excited for back take that
back I don't mean understandable this
it's different people different Vibes
and I'm like hey this is crazy trailer
and I'm going to eat it up that trailer
did get me really pumped I am very
excited I'm gonna be watching all of
that I'm I'm excited to have that I
think it's gonna be pretty fun um my
number two though is a different MCU
series coming in 2024 and of course it
is Agatha darkhole Diaries I am
so excited for Agatha I don't I don't
care what that show ends up being just
think all right just if you were to tell
me hey there's going to be a show that
has kathern Han in it it has Aubrey
Plaza in it has sasher z in it Patty
Leone is in it yeah I don't care what
universe that's in that's I mean hell
yeah I'm I'm in my mistake was
forgetting Patty LuPone isn't it it's
crazy how that meter goes up like 12
notches because they got Patty LuPone
people that are watching this that are
like yeah it's Patty LuPone no it's
Patty LuPone it's Patty LuPone that
that's she's great Patty LuPone is like
I don't even know who to give an example
of what Patty LuPone means to people
that isn't Patty LuPone when she showed
up in BO was afraid I went they got
Patty
LuPone I thought that was so insane when
she showed up in uh Steven Universe I
was like how did Rebecca sugar get Patty
LuPone like she's um so Patty LuPone is
incredible uh famous for famous Broadway
legend for for anyone who's uninitiated
uh has been in pretty much every single
one of Steven son Hy's shows like and
did one of the be like she did an
incredible ladyes who lunch in a Reunion
cast from company she you know she's
been Sweeney tied she was mama Rose and
Gypsy she's been everything she's just
Patty Leone and seeing her as a witch is
the equivalent of like seeing Stevie
Nicks as a witch it's like yeah I
wouldn't be surprised this Legend This
Legend of a human being has knows
witchcraft 100% understandable she's
been using it to make herself uh
Immortal for the rest of her life oh God
and what's your number one my number one
are you ready do it are you ready do it
goes as no surprise that Jessica Clemens
is the most excited for the boys W you
out of your mind you're out of your mind
gen V ruined me in the best way possible
in the best way possible J like I
already love the boys but gen V coming
and tearing it up and reminding me where
I like gen V felt like one of the boys
so much that I was like this is insane
this is perfectly tailored I love how
they're weaving the boys in this and not
heavy-handedly it's more catered to the
the college students what are they gonna
do with the boys now that with the
information that we all got from genv
where can they go keep [__] going I'm
so excited for the boys you're out of
your mind
dude boys is a good pick would you pick
for your number one I should have put
the boys in my top five have that's why
I said but I won X-Men 97 in the Alo
yall leave me alone that's what the
X-Men one W I said interesting cuz I
thought your fifth would be the boys I
was so surprised that the okay fair
enough fair enough I'm still sticking
with Xmen 97 I think because here's I
love the boys I love the boys and geny I
completely agree with you um it does
this thing that house of the Dragon does
where it's I don't want to sound like
Aude but it's just like so violent and
so excessive and while I'd be okay with
the boys continuing to do that they're
also franchising out and becoming
exactly what the MCU is that they're
making fun of you know like they have
the boys Mexico and it's like are you
gonna be able to still have the satiric
edge when you're also just making as
much money as MCU shows are good that's
what they've been doing I love that
they're like mimicking what Disney is
even with VA International TV I'm like
oh yeah here's all their weird TV
programs of their weird celebrity
superheroes I'm like I think that's why
I eat up the boy so much is how like if
if meta is the right word it is I'm just
genuinely like I love the foreshadowing
because I don't eat this up enough but
did I like the forceing with what they
did at the end of gen V absolutely not I
almost threw my head through a TV I
hated the finale of gen V in the best
way possible it was a great finale thank
God they're going to season two or else
I'd run up into Amazon Studios and go
crazy my number one is Andor season 2
okay yeah okay I mean look Andor season
1 was so good I don't care I mean I you
know there's plenty of debate that's
been well tried about you know within
the Star Wars fandom but I just for my
money God Andor just kind of come came
out of nowhere to be my favorite Star
Wars show that came out in 2022 right
yeah that's when that came out I liked
it more than Obi-Wan Kenobi yeah uh
definitely better than the Mandalorian I
liked Andor better than Ahsoka I liked
Andor better than pretty much anything
Star Wars has done and yes some of the
episodes were just kind of like we're
just existing in this world having
interesting conversations right now but
that's what I loved about it and I
knowing what we know about season two is
it's going to be like we started out
five years out from Battle of Yavin and
now we're going to do like a couple
episodes every year getting up it's
gonna feel like Rogue one felt like it's
or specifically the Final Act of Rogue
one where it's just like we're cooking
with gas now I just I mean I was so
blown away by season one I just don't
see how they screwed up for season two I
I'm just so excited I hope they don't
look I hope they don't uh but also Andor
being number one makes sense it makes
sense I think Andor number one makes
sense for a lot of people and so does
the boys for a lot of people yeah oh for
sure it that makes sense Andor is
probably a lot of people's most
anticipated thing and everybody should
go watch it so they get a third season
some things we left off from our list uh
no squid game season two on either of
our lists and I just is it coming out I
think it is coming out in uh in
2024 the reason I left it off was just
like season 1 was so good yes that
showrunner had to come up with season
two pretty fast and it's it seems to me
it's gonna be like a True Detective
thing where that he spent years of his
life developing season one and made it
so good and season two is just gonna
forget like what I don't know I just
have I agree I agree I have concert I'm
nervous about it I I am very nervous
about it I'm G to watch it it's going to
be like what stranger things season 2
was it's Netflix is going to be like
here's another like $80 million to make
a second season they're like okay and
then they don't take as long to write
it what other shows are we missing just
squid game uh we got squid game um
there's probably some oh there's going
to be a new True Detective jod Foster
True Detective season four I think that
will be pretty good oh yeah white there
be White Lotus Thailand right White
Lotus would probably be genuinely my
number six would be number six White
Lotus is always just been great TV you
know like it's so weird and all over the
place great are we getting the bear the
bear got renewed for a third season that
is shooting in 2024 but I don't it might
come out by the end of the year Last of
Us say be is gonna begin shooting in
February I don't think it will come
before December I think it'll come out
in 2025 I think I feel pretty good about
our picks I think we we covered our
bases I mean you didn't put the boys on
your list but yeah there's also umbrella
academ right oh I didn't even put that
on my
list Jess how dare you I know if I could
change it I think Umbrella Academy would
be easily like it would be three it
would be three it would okay solid three
but I I'll keep what my list was but I
love Umbrella Academy and it's their
final season and I'm still going to love
it let us know in the comments below
what we missed uh from from our lists
from our top five movies and top five
shows but that's I mean we're gonna be
covering lots of stuff on new rock stars
in the new year but this is a this is
like the stuff I'm most excited about
and what Jess most excited to watch and
we'll leave it there for this episode of
the sneak peek happy New Year Jess happy
New Year uh be sure to follow new
rockstars on all socials follow Jess at
Lulu Clemens you can follow me at eavas
and uh we'll see everybody in 2025
goodbye no 2024 what year is it yikes oh
my God he's dying eat 12
grapes my baby's crying I have to go um
bye
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
la